I've got some breaking news for you now
we're gonna speak to our political
editor Beth Rigby because we understand
that the government is preparing to
table a motion for a general election on
Monday looks like it's time Beth well it
might not be time Sarah Jane because it
depends on whether MPs vote for it but
political cabinet has just broken up I
was on the steps outside Downing Street
talking door trying to talk to some
cabinet ministers very tight-lipped but
I did catch up with the Chief Whip Mark
Spencer and I asked him whether they
were going to table a motion for a
general election on Monday he told me it
was highly likely subsequently I've been
told by others that the government
indeed are preparing to table a motion
for a general election and as I
understand it they're preparing to table
that motion under the fixed term
Parliament at which requires two-thirds
of MPs to vote for that election for it
to go ahead and I think my maths isn't
great but that's about 434 MP so it's
not nailed on and the reason it isn't is
that Boris Johnson might want that
election but Jeremy Corbyn has made it
very clear that he will not have that
election he will not hold it he will not
allow it until he's absolutely sure that
any risk of No Deal is ruled out on
October the 31st but the interesting
thing about this is that it seems that
the government Boris Johnson met with
his political cabinet to talk about the
options and it appears that they have
decided amongst themselves that trying
to proceed with the withdrawal Act bill
is not their preferred option so trying
to get Boris Johnson's bill through
Parliament not their preferred option
you remember it brought through on the
second reading but now it would be
amended and changed until it passed the
thirdly reading if it did and got into
law that isn't their preferred option it
seems that Boris Johnson's decided that
he would rather go for a general
election before Christmas but as I said
it is not in his gifts he needs to third
of MPs to agree with him and that debate
within Parliament and in the Labour
Party has certainly not been settled yet